Alors l'anneau ou le cercle de
Ferrandez as bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
- Annie je commence avec vous.
- C'est ojet qui va(&(,úthirer n
à tout ce qu'on a vécu les deux
dernières années avec l'COVID.
Ça nous permet de rêver un peu
plus loi pied.
Il y a un point où j'ai un peu
on donne l'explicationa permetx
travailleurs de venir travailler
e-ville, je ne suis pas
sûr.
Ça permet aux touristes de venir
géniale,géniale,géniale,génialee
projet, c'est la fiertémontréal.
C'est fait à Trois-Rivières,
c'est un produit de chinook vaP.
- Luc, qu'en pensez-vous?- Je m.
un autre grand aménagé, ça va
être extraordinaire, je sais pas
si vous avez vu les plans qui
s'en viennent, l'université
formidable verre, coller sur le
centre-ville, et le Mont-Royal.
On ne peut pas avoir un axe plus
grand que ça.
Même dans les grandes villes du
Là, c'est un cadeau qui est fait
par Ivanhoé Cambridge.
Ce n'est pas le seul cadeau,
rétablissement des escaliers
sera déjà donné un coup à
droite.
- Ça libère.
Ça libère cette perspective,
tout était bloqué,
du Mont-Royal jusqu'au centre-
ville, il y a une perspective.
- Absolument.
Il faut dire que Monsieur
Cormier a beaucoup
Il y a toujours un peu d'humour,
il dit que tout était carré
oui, ça fait valoir la beauté de
la place
Maintenant on n'en trouve, on
trouve l........
Cormier s'en vient et où on fait
un rond-point il met defontainec
les chiens, la demie fontaine
c'est un Nomme qui amène
de l'humour dans la ville.
- Annie, vous avez peut-être lut
leur veste, pourquoi on met dele
Montréal avait besoin de ça?
Vous répondez quoi à tout ça.- n
statut de ville internationale,
elle se doit d'avoir des projets
différents, qui sont beaux et
qui nous amène à réfléchir et
qui vont attirer les gens.
de l'or un peu partout, de leurs
permanents.
C'est ce qui donne de la beauté,
c'est ce qui attire.
Je comprends les g
l'or, mais on peut aimer et ne
pas aimer.
Lors va à tout le monde.
Dans une ville, ça nous permet
de voir les chosesans
une ville, on va solliciter les
statuts, les grandes oeuvres
partout.
Dans le centre-ville, le fait
d'avoir le cercle, aussi, on a
e.
Comme un monocle, un oeil.
on réussie.
Il n'y a pas de oui mais.
- Ce n'est pas la tour Eiffel, e
Montréal, c'est le cumule.térese